after winning her multi-million dollar
lawsuit against los angeles county
vanessa bryant is paying it forward kobe
bryant's widow won 16 million dollars in
damages in court it's what a jury said
she deserved for the emotional distress
caused by leaked photos taken from the
scene of her late husband and daughter
gianna's fatal 2020 helicopter crash
we love and miss you boo boo and gigi
so where will the winnings go to a cause
near and dear to the bryant family the
los angeles times reports vanessa plans
to donate funds to the mamba and
mambasita sports foundation a non-profit
that carries on kobe and gianna's
legacies by offering opportunities to
underprivileged young athletes truly
it's a gift
it really is a gift the bryant family
wasn't the only winner in this case the
jury awarded co-plaintiff christopher
chester with 15 million dollars in
damages too he lost his wife sarah and
13 year old daughter payton in the same
crash
just moments after leaving the court
vanessa shared this instagram post in
honor of the victory quote all for you i
love you justice for kobe and gigi and
in a twist of fate the day of the big
win was kobe bryant day aka mamba day 8
24 in honor of his number 8 and number
24 lakers jerseys kobe's former teammate
shaq praised vanessa for standing strong
during the trial telling et he can't
imagine what she's going through
we live in a world where
especially when he hits the internet
people don't care but
those aren't pictures that i would ever
ever want to see so
she's doing a great thing for you know
holding the people responsible
for what they did so how did these
photos get into the wrong hands well
legal expert julie rendellman tells e.t
it's not unusual for photos to be taken
on a crime scene i think the more
significant aspect of it is not as much
whether or not they were
supposed to take those photos but the
mere fact that anyone else would have
seen them is the big problem regardless
of whether or not they were legitimately
taking those photos in the first place
she also goes into detail of why
fighting this case was so important for
vanessa first of all the county
wants the jury to believe that the
reason these photos were taken was
because they were required to be taken
and so the question becomes well were
they really required to zoom up close
uh to the remains of each of the
individuals including kobe bryant and
his child the second reason is the more
gruesome these photos are
the more emotionally distressing it is
to vanessa bryant and her family to know
that individuals that have absolutely
nothing to do and no right to view these
photos had an opportunity to do so